HOPEFULLY IT’S BACK TO NORMAL.
>> Sandra: ABSOLUTELY, WE ALL
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT.
JOHN ROBERTS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Ed: NANCY PELOSI
NANCY PELOSI SAYS LAWMAKERS
MIGHT CONSIDER EXTENDING THE
ONE-TIME CHECK FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
>> WE MAY BE JUST THINKING OF
SOME DIFFERENT WAYS TO PUT MONEY
IN PEOPLE’S POCKETS.
LET’S TEACH WHAT WORKS.
AND OTHERS AND LET’S BRING IN
JONATHAN, GOOD MORNING.
THE REPUBLICANS ALREADY RAISING
EYEBROWS ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS
THE BEST IDEA AND WE HEARD THIS
EARLIER IN THE CAMPAIGN.
>> I DON’T THINK THAT’S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THEY HAD ABOUT STAYING IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, IN THE BUSINESSES.
THAT’S THE SECOND TIME AND
SENATE.
SO WE REACH SOME KIND OF
AGREEMENT BUT AT THE MOMENT --
>> Ed: I WANT TO SWITCH GEARS.
HE IS NOW SWITCHING HIS
DECISION, THE HOUSE IS NOT NOW
RETURNING TO SESSION THIS WEEK.
THEY WERE UNDER PRESSURE AS YOU
KNOW TO GET BACK TO WORK ON SOME
OF THESE ECONOMIC MEASURES.
BUT AS YOU KNOW, AND WE ARE NOT
SURE WHERE ALL THIS IS HEADED.
AND IT’S INTERESTING, IT’S A
CONFINED SPACE.
>> IN THE MEANTIME, A
FASCINATING STORY THIS MORNING,
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" TALKED
ABOUT THIS MAY NOT PROJECT TYPE
GROUP, YOU HAVE THIS ECLECTIC
GROUP OF SCIENTISTS AND
BILLIONAIRES AND ONE OF THE
FOLKS RUNNING IT OUT OF THEIR
BEDROOM IN AN APARTMENT IN
BOSTON.
TELL US WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS
AND WHY PEOPLE OF THE
WHITE HOUSE MIGHT BE INTERESTED.
>> WE PUT THE WHITE HOUSE IN THE
OUTSIDE OF THE GOVERNMENT, AND I
WOULD SAY MORE EFFECTIVE THAN A
TRADITIONAL HOUSE IS TO --
CONVENTIONAL VOICES AND PEOPLE
ON THE OUTSIDE HAVING DIRECT
RELATIONSHIPS.
TRUMP HIMSELF, AND HE LIKES TO
HAVE A VERY, VERY BROAD WAY TO
MICHAEL RAY.
THAT COULD BE VERY IMPORTANT.
MAYBE BRINGING BUSINESS LEADERS
OUTSIDE OF THAT ROOM AS YOU
KNOW.
COULD BE INTERESTING.
>> AND THIS IS DOING IT.
GREAT.
A FASCINATING GUEST, YOU HAVE
NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO
SAME THINGS ABOUT THIS.
>> WE HAVE OUR DECEMBER, THAT
CHINA HAD A VIRUS PROBLEM.
CHINA SAID IT WAS CLEARLY UNDER
CONTROL WE SHOULD HAVE WENT --
THEY ARE SAYING I BLEW THE BUGLE
ABOUT THE WUHAN PROVINCE IN
CHINA.
INTERESTING FOR ONE REASON, ONE
THING IS WE ALL EXPECTED
POTENTIALLY, THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION AND PROSECUTOR IS AN
INDICATION OF HOW THE PRESIDENT
HANDLED IT TO START IN PART, HE
COULD HAVE DONE A LOT MORE.
AND A POWERFUL DEMOCRAT LIKE
ANDREW CUOMO SAYS, I WISH I HAD
DONE IT.
HOW DO YOU MIX ALL OF THAT UP AS
WE GET CLOSER AND CLOSER TO
NOVEMBER?
>> CUOMO IS INTERESTING BECAUSE
IT’S JUST SHOCKING IN
NEW YORK CITY, THE DEATH IN
NEW YORK CITY.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE -- IT WAS VERY
STRIKING TO HAVE A PERSONALLY
THAT STATE.
IT’S ACTUALLY QUITE
SELF-CRITICAL ABOUT
INTROSPECTIVE BUT ALSO HE SAID
THE CHINESE HAVE A LOT TO ANSWER
FOR AND THAT IT DOES ACTUALLY
NEED TO BE A PROPER ACCOUNTING
OF WHAT HAPPENED IN WUHAN AND
WHAT HAPPENED IN CHINA IN
DECEMBER OR JANUARY.
>> Ed: HOLDING CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE TO BE FRONT AND